en primer lugar qué consecuencias crea
usted que pueden tener estas sanciones
que apuntan a la industria energética
rusa serían más efectivas quizás para
frenar la financiación de la guerra
bueno si la consecuencia inmediata e
intentar frenar el flujo de dinero hacia
rusia con la finalidad de finalmente
invertir en en la guerra y lograr sobre
sobre ponerla desde el punto de vista
económico difícilmente éstas van a ser
sanciones que van a modificar o van a
alterar de manera dramática la conducta
de rusia pero son pasos que la unión
europea debe tomar sobre todo
considerando las imágenes de mucha y la
presión política que están enfrentando
los países de la unión
europea hasta este momento no había
planteado este tipo de sanciones lo por
su alta dependencia de los combustibles
rusos cuál es entonces su estrategia
para abastecerse si sanciona el gas y el
carbón de moscú
hay mucha presión para los países
exportadores de crudo de intentar
incrementar la oferta de crudo con
vistas a satisfacer las demandas
mundiales del mismo y también buscar
oferentes alternativos a la propia moscú
lo que no cabe perder de vista es que
inevitablemente la población europea va
a sufrir parte de las consecuencias de
este tipo de sanciones en otras palabras
no es completamente impermeable las
sanciones para la población europea y
ese es el sacrificio que en alguna
medida la misma política europea está
tratando de exigirle a sus ciudadanos y
en su opinión qué efecto han tenido las
sanciones lanzadas hasta el momento han
servido
creo que han servido al menos para
intentar generar algún aspecto de
desestabilización política dentro
denuncia no han cambiado la conducta
pero me parece de que si uno lo estira
en el tiempo uno podría observar algún
tipo de resultado político sobre todo
desde la perspectiva interna de la
federación rusa